some fan favorite shows come to a close
While others are just getting started
these are the shows that will keep your
eyes glued to the screen and your butts
glued to the couch in 2024 just when we
were starting to think we had seen the
last of Charlie Cox's Daredevil
Marvel delighted fans when it announced
that the British actor will be returning
to the MCU for his own series Daredevil
born again at San Diego Comic Con in
2022. the series will build on what
viewers have already seen of Cox's Matt
Murdock and Spider-Man no way home and
She-Hulk attorney at law but the actor
made it clear that his return is not a
continuation of his previous Netflix
series which ended in 2018 speaking to
nme Cox pointed out this has to be a
reincarnation it has to be different
otherwise why are we doing it that's not
the only difference viewers can expect
either since everyone involved in making
Daredevil Born Again wants the series to
appeal to as many people as possible Cox
thinks the tone of the series will be
pretty different my instinct is that on
Disney plus it will be dark but it
probably won't be as gory Cox confirmed
that filming for the 18 episode series
will take place in New York throughout
2023 from February to December with the
series scheduled for a spring 2024
release plot wise Cox imagines it being
very involved health and Matt Murdoch's
work as a lawyer as well as his time
spent as the vigilante hero the actor
will be joined by Vincent D'Onofrio who
plays Wilson Kingpin Fisk the pair
previously worked together on Daredevil
before dinofrio reprized the role in
hakka
the MCU was continuing to roll out new
TV shows and after Daredevil Born Again
Marvel Zombies will expand the superhero
Universe the animated series is based on
the fifth episode of season one of what
if which was titled what if zombies it
depicts what happens to the MCU when
Hank Pym returns from the quantum realm
with a virus that turns The Avengers
into ravenous zombies the new series is
obviously going to continue the Zombies
theme of the episode but it may shy away
from making the Avengers its main focus
according to TV line the Animated Series
reimagines the Marvel universe as a new
generation of Heroes battle against an
ever-spreading zombie Scourge this means
Marvel zombies could be set to introduce
an entirely new cast of Heroes the
outlet is also reported that what if
director Brian Andrews is on board for
the series which has been given a TV MA
rating per screen geek so it sounds like
Marvel Zombies isn't going to be holding
back the mature audience rating means
viewers could see more gory in gruesome
scenes from the undead in 2024
Moana is back but this time for
television in Moana the series The
Animated musical series will continue
telling moana's story following the
events of the 2016 film Disney plus
hasn't revealed much about the upcoming
show but is managing editor of Nerdist
Alicia Lutz noted to USA Today moana's
empathy and compassion make her such an
interesting character the way she helped
the goddess te fiti instead of trying to
Vanquish her was according to loots a
powerful thing to see in a children's
movie especially between two women so
regardless of where the plot takes the
series viewers can expect moana's core
characters rates the shine through the
series will be helmed by David G Derrick
Jr rather than Ron Clements and John
musker who directed the 2016 animated
feature Clements and musker are both
busy with the Princess and the Frog
spin-off Tiana which is on track for its
2023 release Moana the series was on the
same timeline but has since been pushed
back to 2024 to allow more time for
production
yo is reprising her role as the title
character but no other casting
announcements have been made yet so it's
unclear if the likes of Dwayne Johnson
will return for the series Disney could
use the opportunity to throw some new
characters in the mix regardless the
series promises to be an exciting
Adventure we learn more about Moana and
her exploration of the South Pacific
The Walking Dead Universe has been
expanding for years the Show's first
spin-off Fear The Walking Dead came in
2015 and was followed up by The Walking
Dead World Beyond and tales of the
Walking Dead although the Original
Series has now ended airing its dramatic
final episode on AMC on November 20th
2022 there are plenty of stories in The
Walking Dead Universe left to explore
two new shows The Walking Dead dead City
and The Walking Dead Daryl Dixon are set
to bring back some of the universe's fan
favorite characters in 2023 like Maggie
Negan and Daryl Andrew Lincoln and deny
Guerrera are also set to reprise their
roles as Rick and Michonne in an
Untitled spin-off set to Premiere in
2024 variety confirmed that production
on the series would begin in mid-2023
while deadline teased that the series
will focus on the Epic love story of two
characters changed by a changed World
The Walking Dead season 11 finale
briefly teased what is expected to be
the show's starting point with Rick
disappearing into the helicopter and
Michonne searching for him on Horseback
there are long separation has of course
been challenging but the six episode
series will see them reunite at some
point in 2024. Lincoln and Guerrera will
have more creative control this time
around them both actors will serve as
executive producers ingarira is also
credited as a writer on the spin-off
additionally Scott M gimple the chief
content officer of The Walking Dead
universe will be the showrunner also
coming out on Disney Plus in 2024 is
Percy Jackson in the Olympians of
fantasy drama based on the book series
of the same name by Rick Riordan the
series is not a continuation of the 2010
and 2013 Logan Lerman films which were
criticized by fans for taking too many
liberties with the source material
according to a blog post written by
Riordan himself the author is fully on
board with this new series which won't
stray as far from the original story and
it's just so great that I can finally
tell all the readers over the years this
is it this is the adaptation you've been
wanting and waiting for Riordan added
that there are lots of parts to juggle
between the sets special effects and
young lead cast but said he's very
confident there's going to be a great
payoff those young actors Riordan
mentioned are Walker skobel who plays
the Title Character Leah Sava Jeffries
as Annabeth Chase and Aryan Sim Hardy as
Grover Underwood however former Percy
Jackson actor Logan Lerman is an
expected to appear in the series The
Hunter star told E.T that he's always
open to it but later noted to Esquire
that he doesn't think he would be the
right person to play Poseidon as some
have suggested because he doesn't
believe he's old enough for the role
since lerman's interview Toby Stevens
has been announced as Poseidon and the
role of Zeus will be one of the final
roles of the late Lance Redding the
series will adapt the entire first novel
in the Percy Jackson series The
Lightning Thief shooting recently
wrapped on February 3rd 2023 and fans
can hardly wait until the Disney plus
series hits the small screen in 2024
the Hawkins gang is returning for one
last hurray in stranger things season 5
which is due to premiere on Netflix in
2024 speaking to GQ shortly after part
two of season 4 drops actor of David
Harbor outlined the timeline for the
fifth and final season I think we'll
shoot next year we are finishing writing
it this year and they need to prep and
stuff so it would probably come out
mid-2024 based on our track record
series creators The Duffer Brothers have
the story all mapped out now though and
viewers can expect season 5 to have a
time Jump because of how quickly all the
lead actors are growing up Ross and Matt
Duffer have been keeping quiet about the
plot of the upcoming season other than
teasing a Dungeons and Dragons themed
episode however they have revealed to
collider that the series is going to be
another long one they're aiming for
around 10 hours of TV split into Eight
Episodes thankfully that means plenty of
screen time for all the fan favorite
characters
yeah
Additionally the brothers told indiewire
that they're trying to resist bringing
in any new characters so they can focus
on wrapping things up nicely with the
ogs
it always felt like something was
missing when Tom Holland entered the MCU
having already semi-mastered his Spidey
abilities unlike in Tobey Maguire's and
Andrew Garfield's turns as the character
none of Peter Parker's origin story made
it onto the big screen moviegoers never
saw him get his powers or learn to use
them or one of the most pivotal moments
in his life the death of Uncle Ben which
ultimately shapes him into the hero
we've come to know thankfully Marvel
recognized that there was still ground
to cover with Peter Parker's early years
and the Disney plus animated series
Spider-Man freshman year has entered the
fold to fill in the gaps according to
the deadline the show follows Peter
Parker on its way to becoming Spider-Man
hearkening back to the character's comic
book Roots additionally the outlet noted
that Craig of the creek staff writer
Jeff Trammell has signed on to be the
series head writer however not much else
is known about the cast and crew of the
series and it's currently unclear if
Holland will be reprising his role as
the title character
after its initial release in 2020
Bridgerton became Netflix's most
streamed show ever at the time this
means that the streaming giant felt
confident renewing the show for multiple
Seasons it's widely known that season 3
of The Regency drama which is due for
release in 2023 will focus on Colin and
Penelope's burgeoning romance however
it's Benedict's love affair that viewers
can expect to see chronicled in 2024
season 4. while his older brother has
had his fair share of romantic romps in
season 1 and 2. it certainly doesn't
seem like Benedict is in any hurry to
settle down perhaps it's just a matter
of meeting that perfect person if it is
Benedict's love life that season 4
follows then viewers can expect Luke
Thompson to take Center Stage however we
will have to wait a bit longer to hear
who will be playing his romantic partner
Netflix has yet to set an official
release date for the fourth season
following the release of the Robert
Pattinson led the Batman in 2022 it's
full steam ahead on Matt Reeves's bat
verse the film introduced viewers to a
new version of the penguin played by
Irish actor Colin Farrell
how you doing
his performance garnered so much praise
that it wasn't long before Reeves was
setting up a spin-off series based on
the character he also told collider that
the series will be instrumental in
setting up the sequel to his 2022 film
adding that he's super excited about the
evolution of this new universe Pharaoh
previously expressed his excitement
about the series to collider saying I
read the first episode which is just so
tasty and so unusual as the character
was on the page and what Matt Reeves
kind of envisioned when he was thinking
of this iteration of the bang up of Oz
not much else has been announced about
the plot or the cast of the miniseries
but deadline did report that Kristen
milioti has been cast as Sophia Falcone
the daughter of former Crime Boss
Carmine Falcone who was killed in the
Batman Farrell added that he believes
the series will be around 6 or 8 hours
long the penguin is expected to have a
2024 release on HBO Max and Farrell
noted it will be filmed in New York
Reeves later confirmed production would
start in early 2020 3. Korean horror
survival drama squid game became an
instant hit on Netflix when it dropped
on the platform in 2021 the show's
protagonist song Ki Hyun survived the
Twisted game show while his competitors
were executed but he's been totally
changed by The Experience squid game
creator Hong dong Kyo told The Hollywood
Reporter this has left the writer with
an interesting way to move the show
forward saying that Ki hyun's more
selfless nature pushes him towards a new
mystery rather than a family reunion
with his daughter he continued teasing
there will naturally be a flow of events
that will lead all the way to the end of
the season Don Kyo kept quiet on the
particulars of what these events could
be but shared with variety that he
planned to have finished writing the new
series by the end of 2022 so that
viewers could enjoy it on their screens
in 2024
foreign
[Music]